how's it going boss
Who am I I don't even know anymore spend
too long
family friendly Felix family friendly
Felix family friendly Felix will graph
family friendly Felix will rise like a
phoenix
there must be Who I am yes it's all over
the news so it must be true and friendly
buildings and the pretty real family
pretty building and walking
family friendly really family friendly
really friendly really really ha ha ha
this dog is so [ __ ] tight with family
friendly Felix I love money check out
that [ __ ] day by day that's again that's
a new intro song from now on forever
we're keeping this Rick he's done other
ones [ __ ] good channel
thank you hi hon
[Music]
Amaya nasty or am i family friendly
which one is it
I don't know anymore let's see what
other people have to say
PewDiePie boughs to go family friendly
it looks like popular youtuber PewDiePie
is continuing his string of
attention-grabbing antics I didn't ask
you to write the [ __ ] article you did
you did on your own [ __ ] you rewrote
his article based on satire because you
wanted to get an article and you're
calling me out for attention [ __ ] you
Peter pie claims that as a result of
this new policy a third of his videos
have been demonetized cutting into his
income of four million dollars a year so
basically what happened was I in a video
a few days ago I made a joke saying I'm
gonna go family-friendly now it was
clearly a joke if you can't tell that
whenever I wear a hat like that I'm
probably not making a serious thing what
is happening what up it's your boy
PewDiePie big announcement big
announcement big announcement let's get
some excitement everyone got a big
announcement I'm going family-friendly
now but the joke is that I'm going
family-friendly because there's been
some advertiser repercussion on YouTube
it seems that channels that are
family-friendly aren't really affected I
made the joke but it seemed like people
don't understand that it was a joke I
mean look at this satire or serious you
decide they know they know it's that
tired but apparently I'm just doing it
for attention and I think most of my
friends understand that it was a joke as
well but I did see I did see some people
not understanding as well for example
here feeling family-friendly content
also Felix put that in your mouth
because you're a [ __ ] literally a few
seconds later in the same [ __ ] video
clearly I wasn't serious about
family-friendly clearly I don't really
give a [ __ ] okay I my videos have always
been family-friendly your you're getting
this the wrong way as you can tell
they've always been top notch sit down
with your whole family no matter what
age and just enjoy for example such
classics as boobs boobs boobs boobs
boobs boobs boobs boobs boobs boobs
boobs I would say that the only reason
that people get confused whether I'm
actually family-friendly or not it's
because these [ __ ] article are
posting about it since when did it
become okay to write an article about
satire I don't understand why that
somehow accept the book it just doesn't
make sense
PewDiePie vows to go family-friendly as
he suffer major advertisement loss
polygon posted this on ironically and I
slightly call them out on it and then
they make another tweet saying well did
we really take the bait though and then
they're quoting satire amazing so why
write the article in the first place
then especially with the title like that
if you get a report on satire what's the
[ __ ] point
it's like saying PewDiePie sits in a
video that he's gay actually it was a
joke great you just wasted everyone's
time so here it says in the title food
five outs to go family-friendly the
first line in the first line they say
that it's a satirical video but the
problem here is something that I keep
talking about that I keep having to pay
the [ __ ] price for is that it doesn't
say in the title that it's a tire if you
just read the title you will think okay
so Felix is losing a bunch of money and
now he's going to find family-friendly
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] and yeah it's
[ __ ] and you might say okay well
they put it in into this they put it
right underneath they put it here and
the video so you can just check it out
yourself the thing is people don't read
your shitty article they just read the
title and by proving it literally the
first comment saying serves him right
but come on how long do you think it
would really last they are legit
thinking it's true even though in the
article you're saying that it's not why
because they read the title and
I'd say when your network is estimated
around 61 million as I [ __ ] youtuber
you don't ever get to complain where was
I complain egg I get comments from other
people that I don't really know being
like oh so how's your family friendly
thing going like for [ __ ] sakes that was
a joke everyone is posting about it and
it's the exact same thing with all the
Nazi [ __ ]
like I'm really glad that most people
looked into it but there's still a lot
of people that just read headlines and
we're like well I guess I guess he
actually is a Nazi now because I read it
somewhere I don't mean to keep
complaining about these things at the
end of the day I'm just gonna have to
accept that this is who I am and if I
make a joke saying I'm family-friendly
there's going to be articles about it
because apparently that's relevant I
know a lot of people don't like polygons
I always thought polygon was alright but
seeing them keep making articles like
this like reporting on satire I really
think I really think they're better than
that like if you want to be a serious
gaming website why are you making
articles like that I just don't
understand I think you're just making
yourself look stupid like have they no
shame I just don't understand these
people are they that desperate
they must be it's this so bizarre to me
because all Vox media actually isn't it
and polygon owned by box yeah it is well
I should explain it
Gudivada comes out as gay on Twitter you
can't miss it today okay apparently I'm
gay now as well it's too funny it's too
funny these [ __ ] people post about
anything let's see what some of you guys
think about the new family-friendly
Felix meet friendly Felix he's an
extrovert and sociable guy he loves to
spend quality time with his friends and
wait a minute
what's that hand movement
stop let it stop god damn it [ __ ]
honestly I don't know why I even care
like it's not even at least we'll always
have family friendly feelings including
family friendly feelings family pretty
really friendly creepy feeling I'm
putting too much fasik prickly feeling
perfect prickly feeling perfectly
feeling so badly prickly feeling my
videos are ten minutes long
let's say you had a normal 95 kind of
job what if I told you you can do the
exact same amount of effort give give
out more to the people that consume your
products and get three times the amount
of revenue would you not take it I don't
[ __ ] think so okay don't be mad at me
we met at YouTube okay I didn't make up
these [ __ ] stupid ass rules around
ten minutes videos it's [ __ ] stupid i
watch a lot of my older videos like from
2016 a lot of them were like four
minutes five minutes and I think that
works out fine a lot of times but a lot
of times it just feels too short having
a daily video that's just like five or
six minutes it just feels I don't know I
think 10 is the good length anyway what
do you what do you think let me know I
don't it's a lot of more effort like
it's a lot a lot of extra work to get it
to 10 minutes and still keep the same
quality and we're really trying hard to
do that every single day so stop
complaining god damn it